how far around the bend have we got that
we've gone from gang rape
and chortling like his cousin hussein
two do you drink uh have you do you
partake in a schlitz on a tuesday
what's she waiting for
i think what they're doing with brett
kavanaugh is flat out evil
let me ask you this has it changed your
perspective at all i think we're beyond
the idea of fringe or civil disagreement
i think falsely accusing someone of rape
with
no evidence whatsoever is flat out evil
and they know better let me give you
some context here
uh for those who haven't been following
this this week the new york times
dropped another bombshell
that of course caused democrats to call
for brett kavanaugh's impeachment
yesterday democratic candidates called
for kavanaugh's impeachment
senator elizabeth warren said the
nomination was quote
rammed through the senate and former
vice president joe biden asked whether
i was pressured to ignore evidence
whatever we have to get all of that
information out there for the house to
make a decision
on impeachment kamala harris who serves
on the senate judiciary committee
tweeting he was put on the court through
a sham process
and his place on the court is an insult
to the pursuit of truth
and justice and the new bombshells by
the way are
stories that have been reported by
people who can't remember the incident
who weren't necessarily even
there not corroborated by the people or
the victims of the incident so
bombshells
pretty much like this kavanaugh
kavanaugh my best friend sister's
boyfriend's brother's girlfriend heard
from a reporter who found an old
classmate you know this girl who knew
this guy who saw someone put kavanaugh's
stick in a drunk girl's hand last night
i guess it's pretty serious thank you
maddie
no problem whatsoever all right so
before we move on
to the new accusations in detail let me
recap some of the previous accusations
lest you forget it's important to go
back also i was looking for a reason to
use the word lest
christine bless you christine blasey
ford there you go
that's a member truly that's what we
call in in the literary culture
foreshadowing you know talking about
audio papa's prick christine blasey ford
not quarterback he doesn't know okay her
four witnesses let's keep that
let me go here her four witnesses all
denied knowledge of the party
where she claimed to have been assaulted
ford herself she couldn't recall the
place or even the year that it occurred
recently a supporter of ford the main
supporter is now questioning her story
right this comes leland caser told
authors of new book that she didn't
recollect certain facts and that ford's
accusation just didn't make
any sense and so before we move on to
the newest accusations we want to create
a timeline that you understand here in
the top four reasons it's bullcrap
i would actually like to apologize uh
for this ill-timed in looking back
in poor taste joke let me recap this for
you
four accused kavanagh attempted rape and
a letter to diane feinstein that
feinstein didn't mention until after the
hearings feinstein said tuesday she
can't vouch for everything whether it's
true or not four doesn't remember
exactly when it happened or where it
happened her story contradicts the
therapist the attorney story contradicts
forwards an attorney that originally
said ford
would testify is now i think saying that
she's not going to testify was putting
retainer on august at which point she
took a lie detector test for an
accusation she claims
she was never going to make publicly at
all should be noted investigators
are saying that there is still the noted
possibility of ford being a dirty lying
[ __ ] this is
this is the investigators in in light of
recent evidence
and the corroborating witnesses becoming
non-corroborative witnesses i don't know
if non-corroborative if that's a term i
don't even know because usually the
corroborating witnesses don't just do an
about-face
in light of recent evidence i should
have clarified she's potentially
an aspiring lying filthy [ __ ] yeah good
clarification
kavanaugh according to the authorities
not me take it up with your local pd
kavanaugh's other accuser deborah
ramirez yeah
uh initially told ronan farrow that she
didn't have any i don't have i want to
read the quote any stories about brett
kavanaugh and sexual misconduct only to
accuse him later
even after the media outlets contacted
75 classmates wow
no one was able to confirm the report so
uh this recent new york times
article for people have been following
claims seven people corroborated her
claim we'll get back to that remember
julie swetnick a lot of people don't
remember this they think of christine
blasey
she was the one who came forward her
lawyer by the way avenatti
that developed afterwards in case you
forget to totally trust where they get
at the time julie swetnick comes forward
and says brett kavanaugh ran a train on
me
and gang raped remember she said while
cocking his head back and
laughing what is he claw from inspector
gadget i was a gang rapier
i hope i get scotus what is this
avenatti was her lawyer she accused him
of gang
rape he was questioned about that before
the committee
turns out none of it was true she just
happened to see him hand out red solo
cups
on to the latest bombshell in the
problems okay basically the same thing
pretty much basically yeah red solo solo
you're a jerk
and gangrene i don't know here's the
first problem conflation of these claims
okay the article that came out from uh
new york times
it brings out the old claim from ramirez
yeah right that kavanaugh stuck his
penis allegedly in your face and then it
conflates it with a new similar claim
that kavanaugh had his penis out someone
grabbed it and shoved it in the face of
a different woman
the times article claimed seven people
corroborated the claim as they talked
turns out that's completely bogus it's
not even close
none of them were there it's all third
hand it comes down to something just
happened at a party
that's it there was nothing even more
specific remember even after
interviewing 75 classmates the media
couldn't find
a single witness not one to recall you
think for me
at least one you'd think there would be
one and the point is here this money's
the water when you when you add another
almost identical completely
unsubstantiated claim this is my job
and i can't keep track of that one story
came forward someone
brett kavanaugh put his penis in
somebody's face and the other one a guy
committed a sexual assault and grabbed
brett kavanaugh's penis and put it in
somebody else's face
first off this is a very bizarre fetish
it's confusing yeah it's like hey would
you just put my donagher
in this person's face is that it i'm
just gonna stop right there
but when i go home i'm gonna be thinking
about it
by the way hit the notification bell if
you haven't already uh subscribe of
course
these subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot join them up do it lateralcredit.com
because notifications might not even
work anymore half the time they don't
work
i don't care here's a number of pro
another problem this is something people
don't talk about the accuser
okay is a clinton and i use this term
very i'm i'm being careful in choosing
my words
operative a clinton opera is it max
steer
max steyer do we know who i've only ever
read the name yeah i've only read it
don't hold me down it's a stupid name
steel
now the man he accused kavanaugh right
he's described by the new york times as
i want to read the quote this is how
they described him a guy a man who runs
a non-profit organization in washington
oh come on oh that seems positively
benign
no he's a clinical lawyer he was a
lawyer for the clinton specifically mind
you that would be bad enough like you
think conflict of interest
no he was a clinton lawyer with an axe
to grind specifically with brett
kavanaugh due to their history
kavanaugh worked on ken starr's
investigation into bill clinton while
max
was still one of clinton's defense
attorneys problem numbers
done with this guy uh kavanaugh by the
way this is something they've been
talking about they said well the
investigators are made aware we know
that the fbi
the investigation we've heard this a lot
right they claim that the fbi
was made aware of the investigation they
ignored it now here's the thing i read
that at first i think we all read it
and if it were true would be pretty bad
now here's the thing
no it never it never happened they
didn't send
that's the info to those in charge of
the kavanaugh investigation here's what
happened
a senator just notified a member of the
fbi who was not in charge of the
investigation
it'd be like me saying my half asian
lawyer bill richmond complained to susan
wojcicki and he obtained
he complained to someone who offered you
mints at the google headquarters
bathroom
in chelsea none of the details matter
why because here's the main problem
the victim denies that the assault
actually occurs she doesn't know what
she's saying
she denies having any memory of this
supposed assault right
so that's right the anti-kavanaugh
clinton lawyer insists that someone else
grabbed kavanaugh's penis which again
would be sexual assault
thrust it into a woman's face the face
in question however
denies that it rapid seems to me
follow me here if someone thr if if a
complete and total stranger
thrust their pecker into my face
it it would probably be most memorable
to the faced
yes you would be among the first people
to the face that's the victim of the
penis
thrusting no hold on did it make contact
i could be black out drunk all of us
could be blackout drunk last night right
not remember anything except it's a
little bit fuzzy and what i would do
is work my way backwards from the very
memorable event of having a penis shoved
in my face
it would be the only thing i would
remember so when someone says
hold on this is an international story
where we want to get a guy
impeached did he shove his penis into
your face and he said
no no didn't happen i don't know i don't
remember that
no no but certainly there were other
people and they all remember it and then
they're all you know very willing to say
that they saw it and uh
right you know secondary witnesses not
even the victim
and uh alleged here's problem number
five the new york times
oh this is why i think it's evil they
completely omitted this
uh the victim right who had no memory of
it wasn't included
at all in the new york times seriously
yeah
so they talk about it as though as
though this happened they had
information from this alleged victim
who said i don't remember it and that
was not the new york times usually they
just bury these details like 10
paragraphs down right
because usually they post a lie then
they issue some kind of a correction
this time was completely omitted molly
hemingway has done great work she's over
there at the federalist
i want to make sure i give her credit
she got a copy of the book uh from which
the article was taken
and she pointed out the glaring omission
on twitter after that the new york times
added a correction to the article
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
kamala harris has already doubled down
of course this is something that's so
kamala harris she was a prosecutor
correct
she was okay so it seems to me she
should have a basic she should
understand a little a basic grasp of the
law my half asian lawyer bill richmond
has not seen this
okay go ahead
but i want to see what your opinion
might be on a prosecutor
holding this opinion as kamala harris
did based on the new york times article
the fact that something has not been
proven it doesn't mean it didn't occur
right but well right isn't that kind of
a prosecutor's job
imagine that it's like your argument who
knew closing statements well your honor
just because there's no evidence did you
see my tweet though
the judge would say all right yeah
are you serious your honor
can you prove can you prove me wrong
that it didn't not happen
wait i'm very confused i don't i think i
rest my gate thinks that he should be
put in prison for the rest of his life
this prosecutor
she's hilarious and this is why i think
it's evil remember when brett kavanaugh
was being he was asked by cory booker i
think it was cory booker
uh do you ever drink beer on weekdays
brett kavanaugh
you can't even find me a religion you
can't find me a religion that says you
can't drink on weekdays now you can find
religions where they don't drink at all
but there
is no religion that allows you to drink
that says not on weekdays
i'm sitting here going hold on a second
how far around the bend have we got that
we've gone from
gang rape and churtling
[Laughter]
like his cousin hussein to
do you drink have you do you partake in
a schlitz on a tuesday
but she wins rape exactly yeah
this is the damage is already done this
is important just like mattress girl and
uva in case you forgot
those are fake to false rape accusations
make it halfway around the world before
the truth even has a moment to be heard
and as it stands right now
kavanaugh's only crime i will stand
right here and say this until there's
some kind of emerging evidence
he has done nothing wrong not there's a
middle ground
not let's have let's have some kind of
common shared no
he's done zero wrong his only crime is
being accused of
rape by actual dnc candidates
or their lawyers with no evidence
nothing else that's it something else
that's really telling right now
go check huffington post go check salon
go check daley costume go check media
matters
they when the new york times article ran
they were running this look it's going
to be a roadblock for republicans brett
kavanaugh new allegations have come out
since the correction go right now it's
not
anywhere if there is someone who is on
the supreme court who is a gang rapist
or even
shoved his some random passers by face
they would have it front page they know
it's not true and it has been used
as the bedrock for their argument for
impeachment and here's some
none of the democrats demanding
kavanaugh impeachment none of them
backtracked either
since it was revealed that the victim's
claims didn't take place
none of them have backtracked because
they don't have to the new york times
doesn't want them to
the new york times wants this
embarrassment to go away so does the dnc
and so they scream rape at the top of
their lungs and they move on down the
trail to the next slide it's the exact
same strategy they use with donald trump
right the media doesn't want to cover
that russia gate was a lie the dnc
doesn't want to address that it was a
lie and so
the media and dnc decide that they are
going to move on to the next lie
to try and undermine the legitimacy of a
sitting president or a supreme court
justice and this is why i hate it so
much
when people say you know actually this
sjw social justice worry progressive
left is just a fringe
portion of the liberal movement really
really elizabeth warren
kamala harris beto o'rourke bernie
sanders new york times
nbc these are all people in institutions
who have vocally advocated against
constitutional the constitutional right
of due process or the idea of innocent
until proven guilty
as long as the target is a white male
they disagree with so i ask you this
okay to all the moderate liberals out
there i don't even know what that means
anymore it's an oxymoron like a jumbo
shrimp or virgin madonna
all of you moderate liberals out there
when the fringe is in control of the
media
and in control of who will have the
nomination for your party on a national
level
when do you accept that hey maybe
they're not fringe as it relates to the
democratic party
you are hey there youtube viewer if you
like this video click one of these other
videos playing in a box
subscribe hit the notification bell you
may be wondering why after this
outlandish video this is such a straight
end card that's because we've recently
learned that end cards actually
determine the youtube algorithm as it
relates to controversy on a sliding
scale
so we have a yellow and it escalates all
the way to the word